police in Israel have arrested 42
protesters who've been marching against
the government's planned judicial
changes demonstrators as you can see
blocked highway is leading to West
Jerusalem Haifa and Tel Aviv who are
watching live pictures now from Tel Aviv
now on Monday Israel's parliament
approved a bill for a Judicial overhaul
in its first reading protesters say the
new law will limit the Supreme Court's
oversight Powers well let's bring in our
correspondent Imran Khan he joins us now
live from occupied East Jerusalem Imran
these have been an ongoing protests for
some time
that's right these protests have now
been going on for nearly 27 weeks that's
almost six months and today they are
getting bigger and bigger perhaps deals
will be bigger than we've seen in the
past now we saw about 150 000 people out
in the streets of just Tel Aviv on
Saturday the protest movement expects
that number to rise and also the arrests
are rising as well so far 42 people have
been arrested expect that figure to rise
even as we're talking now the reason uh
that the protest movement is going into
overdrive is twofold firstly there was
this reading of a bill for the first
reading of the bill you have to have
three to get a bill passed on the
reasonable standards now what does that
mean it means the Supreme Court is
allowed for example to tell to tell a
cabinet minister that you can't take
office because perhaps he has a criminal
conviction that's their power
this is something that prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu wants to completely
overturn he says it's too much power for
the Supreme Court not so say many many
Israelis and the protest movement who
say that this is just a part and parcel
of democracy now as all of this goes on
the second part of uh this the reason
why they're protesting is the
Parliamentary recess is about to come up
they're going to recess on July 30th at
the end of the month now this means that
the protesters have a limited amount of
time to try and stop the government from
pushing any further bills through so the
protest movement actually is and forgive
the pun they have gone into overdrive
they are now blocking highways that's
something that the Israeli police say
they won't allow them to do but so far
in West Jerusalem they've blocked a
highway they're also protesting outside
of the Supreme Court they're in Tel Aviv
they're in Haifa and they're in
incredibly large number
that Parliament has given this initial
approval just how far are we from this
potentially then becoming law
well there needs to be three readings of
this what happens is there's a first
reading then it goes back to committee
then there's a second reading then it
goes back to committee then there's a
third reading and then the knesset can
pass the law because prime minister
netanyahu's far right Coalition has a
way for thin majority it's been able to
push through a lot of the reforms but a
lot of the reforms have also been
incredibly slowed down as well that's a
victory uh for the protest movement also
Tom Knights the U.S ambassador to Israel
has also been speaking he says he's in
contact with prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu he wants to slow things down
he's looking to that parliamentary
recess as I just explained earlier as a
natural break in somewhere where
negotiations can take place between this
far-right Coalition and the opposition
to try and come up with some sort of
compromise but the government is trying
to push these bills through as quickly
as it can Imran Khan they were the
latest force from occupied easterusalem
thank you Imran